another Star Trek crossover and this one
is genuinely very cool welcome to SRE
your SciFi TV and Movie
[Music]
Channel over at New York Comic Con just
over a week ago Mike McMahon was on a
panel and he was asked about Enterprise
and lower decks and he long story short
basically said that assuming they get a
fifth series of lower decks which is not
certain but assuming they do that we
might get to see some Enterprise love in
that series he was basically teasing us
that they are genuinely thinking about a
lower deck Star Trek Enterprise
crossover episode now why am I so
excited about this and I am a little
excited I'm like a little
bit basically strange new Worlds the
second season I found a little
disappointing I thought the finale
wasn't massively exciting I thought the
musical episode was very disappointing
they really should have done that as a
Christmas special or something it really
annoys me it was the ninth episode of
the Season it really should have been
done as something separate and then I
wouldn't have minded but anyway let's
leave that kettle of fish because it'll
make me angry and I st
ranting but a highlight of the series
really the best episode for me in the
entire
season was the lower deck strange new
worlds
crossover oh hell yeah I did it Mariner
what you what are you doing here I'm
saving you no no no no no we only had
enough
for one trip
oh whoa wait BS did I time travel okay
so is aora here this is amazing
wow you guys are great but is she here
when boyler went through the time portal
I just thought that was fantastic there
was so many real standout moments in
that episode like boyless speed workor
uh Riker
maneuver now whoa
reiker and all these bits I just I can't
tell you how much I loved it it was just
a glorious episode and I've watched it
two or three times since in a season
that for me overall was incredibly
disappointing that and the episode where
they went back in time with um Kirk that
was a good episode as well even though
it made no sense um that was a good
episode as well other than that that was
really a disappointing season now I
don't think strange new worlds or
anybody else should do any other
crossovers I think the live action that
was a one-off and it was done
beautifully um there's a lot of comedy
in there but really they they shouldn't
do it again but lower decks because it's
a comedy show because it's slightly
silly because they get to do things that
are different every episode the last
episode of this season is a brilliant
example of that they basically did a
filler episode with Clips but obviously
it wasn't clips that we'd ever actually
seen before so they created new clips as
if so they were basically poking fun at
a filler Episode by doing just a
brilliant unique episode lowex can do
that it can do that every week obviously
Star Trek has a brilliant history of
this Deep Space 9 with going back to the
trouble with tribles episode who started
it I'm
waiting who started the fight I don't
know
sir all
right
checko I know you you started it didn't
you no sir I didn't well who did I don't
know sir there is a good good history of
doing these Crossovers and doing them
well Mr
War they are
Klingons and it is a long story what
happened some kind of genetic
engineering viral mutation would you not
discuss it with
Outsiders in life
action my problem is going back to
Enterprise going even before the
original series does mean you're going
to have to do some sort of time travel
thing again and it's been done
repeatedly
Captain your presence here has not
been overly
[Music]
metalsome I think he likes you pink skin
I wouldn't go that far but lower decks
could do it in a way that is silly that
would be annoying if they did it in live
action but they can do it in lower decks
because it's the cartoon because it's
silly anyway they can get away with it
they'll make a joke about another time
travel episode you know they'll make it
into part of the show which is something
you couldn't do in a live action now I
actually think I would love to see an
Archer episode of strange new worlds and
this is something that has been rumored
several
times Captain Pike and Archer actually
did live at the same time now according
to Canon Archer did die just four or
five years before strange new world
started for where strange new world is
set but Pike and Archer did live at the
same time for about 30 years so Pike is
a slightly younger man not particularly
younger just slightly younger man could
have met Captain Archer so we could get
a captain Archer episode or getting
getting Scott bacular in a Star Trek
strange new worlds episode quite easily
with just a little bit of a flashback
for some reason it wouldn't break Cannon
there would re no requirement for any
time travel Shenanigans and it could be
something that maybe leads into Pike and
what we know is going to happen to him
in managerie something they didn't
really talk about much in season two
so it's an interesting possibility but
guys what do you think would you love to
see Scott Bill's Captain Archer return
in Star Trek and if he did would you
prefer that was lower decks where they
could really make a joke out of it and
make it fun or would you actually rather
that into something like strange new
worlds where maybe it would have to be a
flashback if they're not going to break
Canon again but let's be honest they're
not bothered about Cannon so actually
Archer could probably just turn up on
the bloody Enterprise and they wouldn't
even bat an
eyelid I personally would prefer Canon
didn't get messed with too much more so
I think actually the lower deck's way of
doing this and giving Enterprise a bit
of love as Mike McMahon said through
lower decks in season five would be
brilliant but get into the comments and
tell me what you think if you are new to
the channel don't forget to like
subscribe hit the Bell notification you
can share the video wherever the hell
you like also you can go to patreon.com
citre where most of our new videos
appear first and you get to see them
without the adverts also you can go to
s.co which is our dedicated website
where we do articles based on most of
our videos and we try and throw in a
little bit more information for you to
digest go check it out as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next
time whoa
[Music]
rord